I want you to meet a remarkable young
woman who will lift your spirits
Cleo Riley is a high school junior who
founded its students for Floyd the group
has inspired thousands of students to
join Cleo at peaceful demonstrations in
Hollywood what are you hoping to achieve
through this organization my goals right
now are obviously just going to protest
and showing that we can get a large
group of kids together to take action
and then we're also leading a bunch of
cleanups to kind of help with the
aftermath of the protests so by doing
the cleanups we show that our
organization cares about our community
we really want to make an effort to help
our community rebuild are you sure
you're only seventeen years ago now if
I'm not mistaken Meagan Markel was a
graduate I've been so inspired by her
because everything that she speaks about
and stands for I think was really
instilled in her at our school dad you
gotta be remarkably proud of her it's
been a real silver lining in these
really you keep on keepin on girlfriends
thank you so much it was great to talk
to you
[Music]